Choiszt: 我没有啊
Choiszt: I didn't.
Choiszt: 就我们我们的那个
Choiszt: Just our, our...
Shure: 哎呦我操
Shure: Oh damn.
Jake:202404 呃
Jake: 202404, uh...
Jake:开了对吧
Jake: It's on, right?
Shure: 我早开了你
Shure: I turned it on long ago.
Jake:都开了都开了
Jake: All turned on, all turned on.
Jack: 你用过hrm吗
Jack: Have you used HRM before?
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alright.
Shure: 来来来他就会蹦出来这个
Shure: Come on, it will just pop up.
Choiszt: 这是傻瓜教学
Choiszt: This is idiot-proof teaching.
Shure: 不我环境都没好呢
Shure: No, my environment isn't ready yet.
Shure: yes
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 然后他会
Shure: And then it will...
Shure: 给我报这个什么
Shure: Report to me this, what's it called...
Shure: trouble shooting some counter package install
Shure: Trouble shooting some counter package install.
Shure: 啦啦啦for example
Shure: La la la, for example.
Jack: 不你你现在放那可是一个新的环境啊
Jack: No, you're setting it up in a new environment now.
Shure: 啊可以
Shure: Ah, okay.
Jack: 对你可也得
Jack: Yes, you still have to...
Jack: 就是缺什么装什么
Jack: Just install whatever is missing.
Jack: 这个绝对最快
Jack: This is definitely the fastest.
Jack: 相信我就是绝对最快
Jack: Trust me, it's the fastest way.
Jack: 对这这你缺什么装什么
Jack: Yeah, just install whatever is missing.
Jack: 今天你回来必给你跑起来
Jack: Today, you'll get it running for sure.
Jack: 哈哈哈这这这坐着三个
Jack: Haha, here sit three people who set up environments daily.
Jack: 这坐着三个天天配环境的人
Jack: You'll definitely get it running.
Jack: 必给你跑起来
Jack: For sure.
Shure: 我相信你们的
Shure: I believe you guys.
Choiszt: 登我号
Choiszt: Log into my account.
Jack: 你就随便可以
Jack: You can just...
Jack: 你看看你拍摄的版本
Jack: Check your version.
Jack: 就3:10一般能用
Jack: Generally, it's usable at 3:10.
Shure: 这个
Shure: This...
Shure: 我跟我
Shure: With me...
Shure: 就跟我那个本地那个一模一样的
Shure: It's exactly the same as my local version.
Shure: 这都是不是
Shure: These are not...
Nicous: 他这玩意只给你下那种正正版的软件
Nicous: This thing only downloads legitimate software.
Nicous: 然后他是那种
Nicous: And then it...
Choiszt: 但你没有激活码
Choiszt: But you don't have an activation code.
Nicous: 对啊
Nicous: Yeah
Nicous: 而且我操他问有没有那个微软的
Nicous: And damn, he asked if there’s any Microsoft stuff
Jake:北邮给了几个微软365的链接
Jake: BUPT gave a few Microsoft 365 links
Jake:但是没有码
Jake: But no codes
Nicous: 我有码我有账号才能给你
Nicous: I have codes, I have an account, I can give it to you
Jack: 我可以一会用
Jack: I can use it later
Jack: 我发给你
Jack: I'll send it to you
Choiszt: 你发我就行
Choiszt: Just send it to me
Choiszt: 不是这不有
Choiszt: Isn't there
Choiszt: 这不有个你
Choiszt: Isn't there one for you
Choiszt: 那个码是哪来的
Choiszt: Where's that code from
Nicous: 腾讯的呀哈哈哈
Nicous: It's from Tencent, haha
其他人：能用吗
Others: Can it be used?
Jake:那能看到腾讯的东西吗
Jake: Can you see Tencent stuff with it?
Jack: 看不到他就是一个激活账号
Jack: No, it's just an activation account
Jake:好
Jake: Okay
其他人：真可以用吗
Others: Can it really be used?
Jake:我们准备买东西
Jake: We're preparing to buy stuff
Jake:我们要买什么呢
Jake: What do we need to buy?
Jake:我们还要补一些
Jake: We still need to restock some things
Jake:还有谁要补
Jake: Who else needs to restock?
Jake:你有要补的东西吗
Jake: Do you need to restock anything?
Jake:你要补酒吗
Jake: Do you need to restock alcohol?
Shure: 补点
Shure: Restock a bit
Jake:补点
Jake: Restock a bit
Jake:你还要补啥
Jake: What else do you need to restock?
Jake:你琢磨琢磨
Jake: Think about it
Shure: 我酒冰饮料
Shure: Alcohol, ice, drinks
Shure: 就饮品上补齐就行
Shure: Just restock the beverages
Jake:路亚要补点什么吗
Jake: Does Lucia need to restock anything?
Lucia:补什么
Lucia: Restock what?
Jake:补什么
Jake: Restock what?
Lucia:哦装饰吗
Lucia: Oh, decorations?
Jake:要补上补货
Jake: Need to restock supplies
Jake:我们要买东西的话你要补什么货吗
Jake: If we're buying stuff, do you need to restock anything?
Jake:雨轩要补货吗
Jake: Does Yuxuan need to restock?
Lucia:如果有蓝色系的明信片的话
Lucia: If there are blue postcards
Lucia:或者
Lucia: Or
Lucia:或者那种装饰纸的话
Katrina: 你找找我那明信片里面有
Katrina: You should check, I might have some postcards
Katrina: 有没有蓝色的
Katrina: Do you have a blue one?
Lucia:啊对也可以就地取材一下
Lucia: Ah, right, we can just use whatever's available.
Shure: 变成那个康纳的那个环境来着
Shure: It's turning into Connor's environment, right?
Lucia:墙上可能需要戳两个
Lucia: We might need to mark a couple spots on the wall.
Lucia:但是当时好像买了也来不及
Lucia: But it seemed like we couldn't buy it in time back then.
Lucia:太不太来得及倒
Lucia: It was too rushed at that time.
Jake:这玩意要收起来了吗
Jake: Should we put this thing away?
Jake:可以收收
Jake: Yeah, we can put it away.
Tasha:先放这吧
Tasha: Let's just leave it here for now.
Katrina: 美文纸跟旺仔牛奶是吧
Katrina: So, it's the fancy paper and the milk, right?
Lucia:我买了他今天应该到了
Lucia: I bought it, it should arrive today.
Katrina: 那那旺仔牛奶是不是要外送
Katrina: So, should we deliver the milk?
Katrina: 要大概几瓶
Katrina: How many bottles do we need?
Tasha: 嗯两瓶
Tasha: Hmm, two bottles.
Katrina: 那就买那种
Katrina: Then let's get that kind.
Katrina: 一板一板
Katrina: The one with a whole pack.
Tasha: 一板就行
Tasha: One pack is enough.
Jake:来我们来记个小本本
Jake: Let's jot this down in our notebook.
Katrina: 黑板可以拿出来了
Katrina: We can take out the blackboard now.
Jake:好啊好啊
Jake: Sure, sure.
Katrina: 户外教学
Katrina: Outdoor teaching.
Choiszt: 你要配那个干啥
Choiszt: Why do you need to match that?
Jake:来来个人抬黑板吧来来来
Jake: Someone help carry the blackboard, come on.
Jack: 你每次每次叼的是同一个吗
Jack: Do you always bite the same one?
Jack: 不知道可能吧
Jack: I don't know, maybe.
Lucia:每次掉的是同一个吧
Lucia: You always drop the same one, right?
Jack: 你别他妈这一盒全部也叼下去了
Jack: Don't just take the whole damn box.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jack: 还是要发挥一些作用
Jack: It still needs to serve some purpose.
Jake:放边上吧
Jake: Put it on the side.
Jake:放放那放这个最左边
Jake: Put it there, on the far left.
Jake:有个音量比较好
Jake: It has a good volume.
其他人：正对阳光
Others: Facing the sunlight.
Jake:正对阳光也行吧
Jake: Facing the sunlight works too.
Shure: 采购装饰打扫甜点QV
Shure: Decorating, cleaning, desserts, QV
Jake:这光是怎么打的
Jake: How's the lighting?
Katrina: 那是我写的m
Katrina: That was my writing.
Katrina: 哈哈哈q and a我不太会画那个符号
Katrina: Hahaha, Q and A, I'm not good at drawing that symbol.
Katrina: 我不太会画那个符号
Katrina: I'm not good at drawing that symbol.
Katrina: 就是地球世界地球日的那个问答
Katrina: It's the Earth Day Q&A symbol.
Choiszt: 哦那还要准备问题是吗
Choiszt: Oh, so we need to prepare questions too?
Jake:对要准备问题
Jake: Yes, we need to prepare questions.
Jake:PPT准备问题
Jake: Prepare questions for the PPT.
Jake:哈哈我们中午准备了一些问题
Jake: Haha, we prepared some questions at noon.
Jake:比如说比如说啥来着
Jake: Like, like what again?
Katrina: 中午那是是问题吗
Katrina: Was that a question at noon?
Lucia:中午那不是问题那只是大家想的
Lucia: That wasn't a question, it was just what everyone thought.
Lucia:就是不是
Lucia: Exactly, it wasn't.
Jake:问题一不孕不育会遗传吗
Jake: First question, is infertility hereditary?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Katrina: 黑板擦没拿是不是
Katrina: Didn't you bring the chalkboard eraser?
Lucia:我觉得不止这个问题
Lucia: I think there's more than just this question.
Lucia:还有什么来着
Lucia: What else was there?
Jack: 是不孕不育是基因突变导致的吗
Jack: Is infertility caused by genetic mutation?
Jake:什么健胃消食片
Jake: What about digestive aid tablets?
Jake:能吃饱吗
Jake: Can they make you full?
Jack: 健胃消食片能吃饱吗
Jack: Can digestive aid tablets make you full?
Jack: 能绝对可以它含糖呀
Jack: Absolutely, they contain sugar.
Lucia:大家都很有逻辑的在回答一些问题
Lucia: Everyone is logically answering some questions.
Jake:对可多了
Jake: Yes, there are so many.
Shure: 现在要干嘛来着
Shure: What are we doing now?
Jake:我们现在盘算盘算要买啥然后去买
Jake: We're planning what to buy and then go buy it.
Jake:你去干嘛
Jake: What are you doing?
Jake:搞币哦你在这搞币吧
Jake: Mining coins? Oh, you're mining coins here.
Jake:为什么每次都能砸中陨石坑
Jake: Why do we always hit the crater?
Lucia:哦哦这个比较搞笑
Lucia: Oh, that's pretty funny.
Katrina: 那黑板擦呢
Katrina: What about the chalkboard eraser?
Jake:在里面
Jake: It's inside.
Katrina: 拿了
Katrina: Got it.
Katrina: 列一下吧
Katrina: Let's list it out.
Katrina: 美文纸买了是吧
Katrina: Did we buy the fancy paper?
Katrina: 他说他买了
Katrina: He said he bought it.
Lucia:应该到了
Lucia: It should have arrived.
Lucia:我今天收到他的取货码
Lucia: I received the pickup code today.
Jake:黑板擦在哪
Jake: Where's the chalkboard eraser?
Tasha: 在哪
Tasha: Where is it?
Lucia:什么这也是奇葩问题吗难道
Lucia: What, is this a weird question too?
Jake:这不是奇葩问题
Jake: This isn't a weird question.
Jake:这是给AI的好问题
Jake: It's a good question for AI.
Katrina: 冰块也有了
Katrina: We have ice cubes too.
Katrina: 那就只要送旺仔
Katrina: Then we just need to deliver Wangzai.
Tasha: 不需要外送了
Tasha: No need for delivery.
Tasha: 我们等会去采购
Tasha: We'll go shopping later.
Katrina: 我们等会出去买呀
Katrina: We'll go buy it later?
Tasha: 对啊我们等会出去
Tasha: Yeah, we'll go out later.
Katrina: 我们等会要出去买啊
Katrina: We'll go out to buy it later?
Jake:出去买
Jake: Go out to buy it.
Katrina: 哦
Katrina: Oh.
Jake:也可以不出
Jake: Or we don't have to.
Jake:可以派一波人出去买
Jake: We can send a group to buy it.
Tasha:没网我靠我说呢
Tasha: No internet, I knew it.
Jake:最近天太好了
Jake: The weather has been too good lately.
Jake:竟然都不下雨
Jake: It hasn't rained at all.
Jake:HTTPL没网了
Jake: HTTPL has no internet.
Jake:服务器没网了
Jake: The server has no internet.
Jack: 我他本地没网
Jack: My local has no internet.
Shure: 不是这是服务器的啊
Shure: No, it's the server.
Katrina: 采购清单
Katrina: Shopping list.
Jack: 啊这服务器的
Jack: Ah, it's the server.
Jake:服务器没网了
Jake: The server has no internet.
Jake:没钱了
Jake: No money.
Shure: 怎么可能
Shure: How is that possible?
Shure: 我今天早上刚给他充100
Shure: I just topped it up with 100 this morning.
董超超你：是不是没有
Jack: Didn't you?
其他人：来看看
Others: Let's take a look.
Jack: 就你没开Brox的
Jack: You didn't open Brox.
Choiszt: 哎这不这可以
Choiszt: Hey, isn't this possible?
Jack: 这不能装吗
Jack: Can't this be installed?
Jack: 这么快啊
Jack: So fast?
Lucia:我刚才一直看那张纸
Lucia: I was just looking at that paper.
Jake:是吧
Jake: Right?
Jack: 一秒一秒跑90%
Jack: It's running 90% per second.
Shure: 这5005百k每秒的
Shure: This is 500, 500k per second.
Shure: 不可能这绝逼是假的这个东西
Shure: No way, this has to be fake.
Jake:catch肯定是catch cash
Jake: It must be cache, definitely cache.
Shure: 什么叫clash
Shure: What do you mean by clash?
Shure: cash是什么意思
Shure: What does cash mean?
Jake:缓存
Jake: Cache.
Lucia:cethe那个单词吗
Lucia: Is that the word "cache"?
Jake:CHE对CHE对
Jake: CHE, right, CHE.
Lucia:che
Lucia: che
Lucia:che  sorry
Lucia:哦原来那个文件夹是这个意思
Lucia: Oh, so that's what the folder means.
Jake:嗯是
Jake: Yeah, that's right.
Jake:就随便删的意思
Jake: It means you can delete it freely.
Lucia:我想搁那整理自己的那个啥
Lucia: I was planning to put my stuff there.
Lucia:系统的时候
Lucia: When I was organizing the system.
Tasha:靠
Tasha: Damn.
Katrina: 上次那个葡萄汁兑酒好喝吗
Katrina: How was the grape juice mixed with alcohol last time?
Lucia:葡萄汁
Lucia: The grape juice?
Katrina: 上次是他
Katrina: It was him last time.
Katrina: 你喝的葡萄是吗
Katrina: Did you drink the grape juice?
Lucia:哦那个我喝了一口
Lucia: Oh, I took a sip.
Lucia:我觉得一般吧
Lucia: I thought it was just okay.
Lucia:不过看大家了
Lucia: But it's up to everyone.
Katrina: 我感觉西柚的蛮好喝哦
Katrina: I think the grapefruit one is quite good.
Jake:好西柚可以
Jake: Alright, grapefruit is good.
Lucia:呃西柚的比葡萄的好喝一点
Lucia: Uh, the grapefruit one is a bit better than the grape one.
Katrina: 那橙汁的我也觉得一般般
Katrina: I also think the orange juice one is just so-so.
Lucia:因为我们上次买的是朗姆
Lucia: Because we bought rum last time.
Jake:就西柚疯狂西柚
Jake: Just go crazy with the grapefruit.
Katrina: 那只买
Katrina: Then only buy...
Lucia:就是橙汁
Lucia: Just orange juice.
Lucia:其实应该兑龙舌兰
Lucia: Actually, it should be mixed with tequila.
Katrina: 哦我们现在有奶
Katrina: Oh, we have milk now.
Katrina: 那要不要再买一瓶气泡酒
Katrina: Should we buy another bottle of sparkling wine?
Lucia:气泡酒还有一瓶
Lucia: We still have a bottle of sparkling wine.
Lucia: 有一个那个金色的那个气泡酒
Lucia: There's a golden bottle of sparkling wine.
Jack: 买那个旺仔牛奶
Jack: Buy that Want Want milk.
Jack: 那个旺仔牛奶配百利甜
Jack: That Want Want milk goes well with Baileys.
Lucia:你要甜死我
Lucia: You're going to make me sick with sweetness.
Choiszt: 好像还是能下
Choiszt: I think it might still go down.
其他人：红石榴长江龙舌兰日出
Others: Pomegranate, Changjiang, Tequila Sunrise.
Katrina: 咱咱还有什么酒来
Katrina: What other alcohol do we have?
Katrina: 那一瓶是什么呀
Katrina: What's that bottle?
Katrina: 还有什么酒
Katrina: What other alcohol do we have?
Katrina: 气泡气泡的有一瓶
Katrina: We have one bottle of sparkling.
Lucia:39 那个开了
Lucia: The 39, that one's opened.
Shure: 汽个气气泡的
Shure: Sparkling, we have a bottle of sparkling.
Katrina: 然后还有呢
Katrina: And what else?
Katrina: 还有就是朗姆的半瓶
Katrina: And there's half a bottle of rum.
Lucia:郎姆小半瓶现在
Lucia: Half a bottle of rum now.
Katrina: 那就是一些吃的
Katrina: Then there's some food.
Shure: 你可以你是不是一会不去对吧
Shure: Are you not going later, right?
Shure: 买东西的话
Shure: If you’re buying stuff...
Lucia:不过我觉得百利甜值得考虑
Lucia: But I think Baileys is worth considering.
Lucia:因为不太会踩雷
Lucia: Because it's not likely to be a miss.
Lucia:不过我觉得
Lucia: But I think...
Lucia:刚才谢明竹说那个百利甜值得考虑
Lucia: Just now, Xie Mingzhu said Baileys is worth considering.
Lucia:因为感觉不是太会踩雷
Lucia: Because it doesn't seem like a miss.
Lucia:可能大家会比较想
Lucia: Maybe people would prefer it.
Lucia:百百利甜是一种甜酒
Lucia: Baileys is a type of sweet liquor.
Jack: 我靠还买了香槟
Jack: Whoa, you even bought champagne.
Lucia:利口酒
Lucia: It's a liqueur.
Shure: 也不是香槟吧
Shure: It's not champagne, right?
Shure: 就气泡酒
Shure: It's just sparkling wine.
Tasha: 香槟
Tasha: Champagne.
Lucia:反正一般女生会比较不踩雷
Lucia: Generally, girls are less likely to dislike it.
Lucia:喝那个的话
Lucia: If they drink that.
Tasha: 说要买瓶香槟
Tasha: They said to buy a bottle of champagne.
Katrina: 香槟真的假的
Katrina: Champagne, really?
Katrina: 那个
Katrina: That...
Shure: 那个就行
Shure: That will do.
Lucia:那个就行吧应该
Lucia: That should be fine, I guess.
Shure: 嗯能崩一下
Shure: Yeah, it can pop a bit.
Shure: 就就就可以了
Shure: That’s good enough.
Katrina: 北冰洋还要买吗
Katrina: Should we buy Beibingyang?
Katrina: 哦哦可乐没了
Katrina: Oh, we're out of Coke.
Jack: 刚我看上面不是毕延了吗
Jack: Didn't I see it up there just now?
Tasha:茶
Katrina: 茶是什么
Katrina: 茶
Katrina: 茶这样写吗
Lucia:就那个维他柠檬茶
Lucia: It's that Vita lemon tea.
Tasha: 直接叫茶吗
Katrina: 哪个叫什么
Katrina: Which one is called what?
Katrina: 什么是茶啊
Katrina: 是茶啊
Tasha: 维他茶
Tasha: Vita tea.
Lucia:反正在我们
Lucia: Anyway, in our...
Katrina: 哦我以为他写了哈哈
Katrina: Oh, I thought he wrote it, haha.
Lucia:反正在我们的目标观众地区
Lucia: Anyway, in our target audience area...
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Lucia:我刚那句话要不要删掉
Lucia: Should I delete what I just said?
Jake:呵呵呵部分
Jake: Hehehe, partly.
Jake:部分合法
Jake: Partly legal.
Katrina: 你还需要草莓吗
Katrina: Do you still need strawberries?
Jake:部分合法
Jake: Partly legal.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yes.
Tasha: 蓝莓是不是没拆
Tasha: Haven't the blueberries been unpacked?
Katrina: 蓝莓吃掉了啊
Katrina: The blueberries were eaten.
Tasha:啊什么时候
Tasha: Oh, when?
Tasha: 什么时候吃掉的
Tasha: When did you eat them?
Tasha:为什么没带我
Tasha: Why didn't you take me?
Katrina: 洗了那一天不知道什么
Katrina: The day we washed them, I don't know...
Lucia:前两天吧好像
Lucia: A few days ago, I think.
Tasha: 为什么没带我
Tasha: Why didn't you take me?
Lucia:因为那个如果再放好像就会坏
Lucia: Because if we left them any longer, they would have gone bad.
Lucia:所以我们就已经把它吃掉了哈哈
Lucia: So we just ate them already, haha.
Tasha: 那就买草莓和蓝莓还有
Tasha: Then let's buy strawberries and blueberries, and...
Katrina: 青提可以兑酒
Katrina: Green grapes can be mixed with wine.
Katrina: 青提
Katrina: Green grapes.
Tasha: 青提还有榴莲
Tasha: Green grapes and durian.
Jack: 你已经熟练的使用度假工具
Jack: You have become proficient at using vacation tools.
Katrina: 你要榴莲是吧
Katrina: You want durian, right?
Katrina: 你喜欢吃榴莲是不
Katrina: You like eating durian, don't you?
Tasha: 嗯哎
Tasha: Yeah, hey.
Lucia:哎我们之前买那盒榴莲吃完了吗
Lucia: Hey, did we finish the box of durian we bought earlier?
Tasha: 他偷偷吃掉了
Tasha: He ate it secretly.
Jake:我怎么偷偷吃了
Jake: How did I eat it secretly?
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahaha.
Jake:塞我嘴里了
Jake: It was stuffed into my mouth.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia:塞我嘴里
Lucia: Stuffed into my mouth.
Tasha: 你吃没吃
Tasha: Did you eat it?
Jake:吃了吃了
Jake: Yes, I did.
Jake:确实吃了
Jake: I really did.
Tasha: 你看他偷偷吃掉了
Tasha: See, he ate it secretly.
Shure: 猫也挂着呢
Shure: The cat is also hanging around.
Shure: 我给你开global行不
Shure: Can I get you global access?
Jake:有个上海的电话
Jake: There's a call from Shanghai.
Katrina: 上海谁给我打电话
Katrina: Who's calling me from Shanghai?
Jake:上海电话
Jake: A call from Shanghai.
Jack: 上海邮电大学
Jack: Shanghai University of Posts and Telecommunications.
Jake:上海邮电大
Jake: Shanghai University of Posts and Telecom.
Shure: 唉
Shure: Hey.
Katrina: 那明天就是那个串要买吗
Katrina: So, are we buying those skewers tomorrow?
Jake:串就美团吧
Jake: Let's just get them from Meituan.
Katrina: 烤吗
Katrina: Grilled, right?
Jake:美团吧明天买
Jake: Yeah, let's buy them from Meituan tomorrow.
Katrina: 那就烤点串
Katrina: Then let's grill some skewers.
Katrina: 然后那个炭啊什么的都有了是吧
Katrina: So, we have charcoal and all that, right?
Tasha: 我们美团买的
Tasha: We bought it from Meituan.
Tasha: 意思是美团烧烤店买
Tasha: I mean, from a Meituan barbecue shop.
Tasha: 哈哈哈然后来
Tasha: Haha, and then...
Jake:哈哈哈买点炭灰哈哈哈
Jake: Haha, let's buy some charcoal ash, haha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Lucia:又是一个弱智吧问题
Lucia: Another dumb question, huh?
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:明天要是这天气就太阳能烤
Jake: If the weather's like this tomorrow, we can grill with solar power.
Katrina: 还有那个如果说要唱歌的话
Katrina: And if we want to sing, can your sound system connect to a microphone?
Katrina: 你音响能接话筒吗
Katrina: Do you have a microphone?
Katrina: 有话筒吗
Katrina: Any microphones?
Shure: 没有话筒
Shure: No microphones.
Jake:没有话筒怎么搞
Jake: How are we supposed to do it without a microphone?
Shure: 买花租买花租
Shure: Buy, rent, buy, rent.
Shure: 买话筒
Shure: Buy a microphone.
Katrina: 租吧
Katrina: Let's rent one.
Jack: 拼多多9块9话筒
Jack: Pinduoduo has microphones for 9.9 yuan.
Jake:哦真的
Jake: Oh, really?
Katrina: 那种就小小的一个话筒
Katrina: Those small microphones.
Tasha:小唱吧
Tasha: Like a mini karaoke.
Shure: 大概一话筒就100多块钱搞一个
Shure: A decent microphone costs over 100 yuan.
Tasha: 租一个吧
Tasha: Let's rent one.
Tasha: 现在买还来得及吗
Tasha: Can we still buy one now?
Shure: 费劲
Shure: Too much hassle.
Alice:明天天气比今天再热一点哦
Alice: Tomorrow's weather will be even hotter than today.
Jake:真的
Jake: Really?
Tasha: 怎么要买空调吗
Tasha: Are we buying an air conditioner?
Jake:哈哈哈室外空调大风扇
Jake: Hahaha, an outdoor air conditioner, a big fan.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahaha.
其他人：买那个买那个
Others: Buy that one, buy that one.
其他人：烤肉用的
Others: For BBQ.
其他人：烤肉用的超大
Others: Super big for BBQ.
Tasha: 冰风扇那种是吗
Tasha: Like an ice fan, right?
Katrina: 哎是不是那个小青柠还在呢
Katrina: Hey, is that little lime still there?
Tasha: 在呢
Tasha: Yeah, it's still there.
Katrina: 芒果还需要吗
Katrina: Do we still need mangoes?
Tasha: 需要什么来着
Tasha: What else do we need?
Tasha: 不要了
Tasha: We don't need it anymore.
Shure: 哦也有哎
Shure: Oh, there's that too.
Lucia:我们就应该买龙舌兰的
Lucia: We should buy tequila.
Tasha: 干嘛干嘛干嘛
Tasha: Why, why, why?
Lucia:哦没事
Lucia: Oh, nothing.
Lucia:我就随口一说
Lucia: I just said it casually.
Jake:下下午2点半
Jake: At 2:30 in the afternoon.
Lucia:如果大家觉得能喝完的话
Lucia: If everyone thinks we can finish it.
Katrina: 要不就把朗姆换成龙舌兰
Katrina: How about we replace the rum with tequila?
Katrina: 都行我不太懂
Katrina: I'm fine with it, I don't really know.
Lucia:今天今天买酒还买朗姆吗
Lucia: Are we still buying rum today?
Katrina: 换那就换呗
Katrina: Replace it then.
Lucia:那就换龙舌兰呗
Lucia: Then let's get tequila.
Lucia:就是大家可以尝尝不同的口味吗
Lucia: So everyone can try different flavors.
Jake:早早点来早点来
Jake: Come earlier, come earlier.
Choiszt: 音响就用你现在这个对
Choiszt: Just use this sound system, right?
Katrina: 什么话筒
Katrina: What about the microphone?
Katrina: 有是吗
Katrina: Do we have it?
Shure: 话筒北邮有
Shure: The microphone, there's one at Beiyou.
Shure: 有他们来的时候给我取了就行
Shure: When they come, they can get it for me.
Katrina: 借一下呗
Katrina: Just borrow it.
其他人：你要把这个带过来
Others: You need to bring this over.
Jake:什么东西
Jake: What is it?
其他人：推波波
Others: Push ball.
Jake:台球
Jake: Billiards.
Lucia:你刚才做的我还以为是小提琴
Lucia: What you were doing just now, I thought it was a violin.
其他人：这不是很像推波波
Others: Doesn't it look like push ball?
Jake:你们都狠着打的
Jake: You guys are all playing hard.
Katrina: 你主要是你的那个缺还缺啥材料吗
Katrina: Mainly, do you still need any materials for that?
Tasha:好像不缺啥了
Tasha: Seems like we don't need anything else.
Tasha: 我的妈呀
Tasha: Oh my gosh
Shure: 听说你叫北邮奥沙利文
Shure: I heard you're called the O'Sullivan of Beiyou
Jake:我们一辆车能抓几个人
Jake: How many people can we catch in one car?
Shure: 如果是6个人去的话就可以
Shure: If six people go, it should be fine
Shure: 有个人能留在这帮我配环境
Shure: Someone can stay here and help me set up the environment
Jake:哈哈哈要不然就是你吧
Jake: Hahaha, why don't you do it then
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Jack: 那你可以在这配环境
Jack: Then you can stay here and set up the environment
Jack: 不是你先搞一个贝斯
Jack: First, get the base ready
Jack: 你贝斯如果搞好剩下就只等时间
Jack: Once the base is ready, the rest is just waiting for time
Jack: 你可以把开放式装起来就走
Jack: You can set up the open part and then leave
Jack: 回来就装好
Jack: When you come back, it will be done
Shure: 他现在自己在这装呢
Shure: He's setting it up himself now
Shure: 我可以再开一个命令行一起装吗
Shure: Can I open another command line to set it up together?
Jack: 别我建议吧
Jack: No, I suggest not
Shure: 啊好
Shure: Ah, okay
Jake:哈哈哈嗯好介意
Jake: Hahaha, alright, we mind
Shure: 那这个他5下载速度是500K每秒
Shure: His download speed is 500K per second
其他人：现在挺好吧
Others: It's good now, right?
Shure: 我估计差不多
Shure: I think it's about right
Shure: 回来它能装好都不错了是吧
Shure: If it installs fine when we come back, it’s good, right?
Jake:行啊走吧走吧走吧
Jake: Alright, let's go, let's go, let's go
Shure: 咱们全全员都去是吧
Shure: We're all going, right?
Jake:两辆车走吧
Jake: Let's take two cars
Tasha:12341234
Tasha: 1234, 1234
Alice:我在家吧
Alice: I'll stay home
Alice:我在家吧在家等着那个快递
Alice: I'll stay home and wait for that package
Jake:行那
Jake: Alright then
Tasha: 12341234
Tasha: 1234, 1234
其他人：对的一个能4个
Others: Yes, one can fit 4
其他人：一个能5个
Others: One can fit 5
Jake:走打车去哪啊
Jake: Let's go, get a cab, where are we going?
Jake:我们别去
Jake: Let's not go there
Jake:我们换一家超市
Jake: Let's go to another supermarket
Shure: 那你们有山姆会员吗
Shure: Do you guys have a Sam's Club membership?
Tasha: 建议山姆的话有18公里那么远了
Tasha: If we're going to Sam's Club, it's 18 kilometers away
Jack: 稍微远一点好像有通州去万达
Jack: A bit further, there's one in Tongzhou, Wanda
Lucia:那个在通州北苑那是吧好像
Lucia: That one is in Tongzhou Beiyuan, right?
Jack: 挺近的反正我好像看到
Jack: It's pretty close, I think I saw it
Shure: 只要有超市的地方要去
Shure: Anywhere there's a supermarket, we should go
Tasha: 超市超市啊
Tasha: Supermarket, supermarket, huh?
Jake:超市儿
Jake: Supermarket.
其他人：那就万达呗卧槽七公里
Others: Then let's go to Wanda, damn, it's seven kilometers away.
Jack: 七公里开车二十多分钟
Jack: Seven kilometers, driving will take more than twenty minutes.
Shure: 他是卡了吗
Shure: Is he stuck?
Shure: 他怎么不动弹呢
Shure: Why isn't he moving?
Jake:万达超市是什么超市
Jake: What kind of supermarket is Wanda?
Jack: 永辉
Jack: Yonghui.
Shure: 永辉吧
Jake:永辉
Jake: Yonghui.
Jake:可以可以
Jake: Okay, okay.
Jake:那就去永辉
Jake: Then let's go to Yonghui.
Jake:去永辉好
Jake: Going to Yonghui is good.
Jake:我没买没买
Jake: I didn't buy it, didn't buy it.
Jake:没设计出来
Jake: Didn't design it.
Shure: 他这有一个完完整的教程
Shure: He has a complete tutorial here.
Shure: 你就按着他来就行
Shure: Just follow it exactly.
Jake:回回头P一下
Jake: I'll Photoshop it later.
Shure: 这个可能要装很久
Shure: This might take a long time to install.
Shure: 然后他他现在卡在这了
Shure: Now it's stuck here.
Shure: 他如果erro的话你就按下上键
Shure: If it errors, press the up key.
Shure: 然后你再按下回车
Shure: Then press Enter.
Shure: 哎算了我手机控制吧
Shure: Eh, forget it, I'll control it with my phone.
Jack: 你还可以这么牛逼
Jack: You can do that? That's impressive.
其他人：卧槽这个我真hold不住
Others: Damn, I really can't handle this.
Jack: 手机控电脑
Jack: Controlling the computer with your phone.
Jake:就万达是吧
Jake: So, we're going to Wanda, right?
Nicous: 啊这附近有个物美
Nicous: Yeah, there's a Wumart nearby.
Tasha:喉咙痛
Tasha: Sore throat.
Lucia:今天好热呀
Lucia: It's so hot today.
Tasha:是的嘞
Tasha: Yeah, it is.
Tasha: 明天更热
Tasha: It'll be even hotter tomorrow.
Lucia:嗯
Lucia: Uh-huh.
Tasha: 我说明天更热了
Tasha: I mean, it'll be even hotter tomorrow.
Tasha: 我好像没有吃啥
Tasha: I don't think I've eaten anything.
Tasha: 感觉喉咙里面有刀片一样
Tasha: Feels like there's a blade in my throat.
Tasha:没事
Tasha: It's okay.
Tasha:吸到烟味了
Tasha: Inhaled some smoke.
Lucia:哦这样
Lucia: Oh, I see.
Jake:刘帅哪去了
Jake: Where did Choiszt go?
Katrina: 你要看一下有没有蓝色吗
Katrina: Do you want to check if there's any blue?
Katrina: 好像有唉
Katrina: Looks like there is.
Lucia:嗯哎我觉得可以
Lucia: Hmm, I think this will work.
Lucia:那我就蹭你这个好了
Lucia: I'll just use yours then.
Katrina: 你拿吧反正也做不完
Katrina: Go ahead, I won't finish it anyway.
Katrina: 没几朵花
Katrina: There aren't many flowers left.
Lucia:谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Katrina: 反正是杨老
Katrina: Anyway, it's on Jake.
Katrina: 板报销的
Katrina: He's paying for it.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia:哈哈哈
Tasha: 有啊
Tasha: Yes.
Tasha: 在在车上玩了
Tasha: I was playing in the car.
Tasha: 你你你不是又要说我啊
Tasha: You, you, you're not going to scold me again, right?
Tasha:这次真的不会输给我
Tasha: This time you really won't beat me.
Lucia:我们今天的快递是还没送过来吗
Lucia: Has our package not arrived yet today?
Tasha: 你你能打过我吗
Tasha: Do you think you can beat me?
Tasha: 不要
Tasha: No way.
Tasha: 行稍等
Tasha: Alright, wait a moment.
Tasha: 我去拿一下
Tasha: I'll go get it.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Lucia:啊你给小狗做了花花好好看
Lucia: Ah, you made flowers for the puppy, they look great!
Jake:哦插脑袋上了
Jake: Oh, you put them on its head.
Katrina: 还有充电宝吗
Katrina: Do we have any more power banks?
Tasha: 平板平板你在哪里呢
Tasha: Tablet, tablet, where are you?
Tasha: 靠你是不是瞎
Tasha: Are you blind?
Tasha: 眼睛是不是瞎
Tasha: Are your eyes blind?
Jack: 刘帅改变了主意
Jack: Choiszt changed his mind.
Jake:所以我们先去哪儿
Jake: So, where are we going first?
Shure: 刘帅才干嘛去了
Shure: Where did Choiszt go?
Jake:他在外面坐着呢
Jake: He's sitting outside.
Shure: 啊哈
Shure: Aha.
Shure: 那我们现在干嘛
Shure: So, what are we doing now?
Jake:打电话问问呗
Jake: Let's call and ask.
Jake:问问物美你档次够不够啊
Jake: Ask if Wumart is good enough.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Shure: 没办法京爷就是这个样子的
Shure: There's no choice, that's just how Jingye is.
Lucia:你什么档次也敢出镜哈哈哈
Lucia: You dare to appear on camera with that level, haha.
Jake:你这跟永辉比比谁强
Jake: You compare with Yonghui, see who's better.
其他人：你家有旺仔牛奶
Others: Do you have Wangzai milk at home?
Jack: 我问他你什么成分
Jack: I asked him, what's your background?
Jack: 感觉永辉出现在同一个风口
Jack: It feels like Yonghui appeared at the same time.
其他人：蓝莓草莓蓝莓草莓
Others: Blueberries, strawberries, blueberries, strawberries.
Tasha:真要打电话问啊
Tasha: Really need to call and ask?
Choiszt: 我问一下他们几层喂
Choiszt: Let me ask them which floor it is.
Choiszt: 你好那个问一下你那个超市几层啊
Choiszt: Hello, can I ask which floor your supermarket is on?
其他人：我问超市几层
Others: I'm asking which floor the supermarket is on.
Jack: 大吧
Jack: Big, right?
Jake:有有有有有这些东西吗
Jake: Do you have these things?
Jack: 你家有旺仔牛奶龙舌尾
Jack: Do you have Wangzai milk and Longshewei?
Nicous: 我第一次见
Nicous: It's my first time seeing this.
Tasha: 疯了
Tasha: Crazy.
Tasha: 你们家什么档次
Tasha: What's the standard at your place?
Jack: 那你跟杨老板出去吃饭
Jack: Then you went out to eat with Jake.
Jack: 杨老板问你烤这个牛他妈的
Jack: Jake asked you to grill this beef.
Nicous: 卧槽他问你烤这个牛肉
Nicous: Damn, he asked you to grill this beef.
Jack: 这个牛肉
Jack: This beef.
Jack: 是是是牛肉吗
Jack: Is this beef?
Jack: 哪个哪个哪个
Jack: Which, which, which one?
Jake:什么什么东西
Jake: What, what is it?
Tasha: 他他说吗
Tasha: Did he say?
Jack: 是吃烤肉
Jack: Eating barbecue.
Jack: 这个是牛肉吧
Jack: This is beef, right?
Shure: 送给
Shure: Giving it.
Nicous: 什么牛什么牛的肉
Nicous: What kind of beef, what kind of beef is it?
Jack: 什么牛的肉
Jack: What kind of beef?
Jack: 什么部位的肉
Jack: What part of the beef?
Tasha: 他问的吗
Tasha: Did he ask?
Jack: 他长在什么地方
Jack: Where does it grow?
Jack: 吃什么草
Jack: What does it eat?
Jack: 他叫什么名
Jack: What's its name?
Nicous: 哈哈哈长在猪身上
Nicous: Haha, it grows on a pig.
Tasha:是你问的吗
Tasha: Did you ask?
Jake:是我问的
Jake: Yes, I asked.
Choiszt: 那个问了说两层
Choiszt: They said it's on the second floor.
Choiszt: 就这个自己的声音还有吗
Choiszt: Do we still have our own voices?
Choiszt: 要去去永辉来回一个小时
Choiszt: It takes an hour to go to Yonghui and back.
Choiszt: 然后咱再买完估计回来都快6点了哦
Choiszt: Then after we buy everything, it'll probably be 6 PM.
Choiszt: 现在已经3点半了
Choiszt: It's already 3:30 now.
Tasha: 我肯定要带这个呀
Tasha: I definitely need to bring this.
Tasha: 我不会用手机
Tasha: I don't know how to use a phone.
Tasha: 玩手机界面好像跟这个界面不一样
Tasha: The phone interface seems different from this one.
Nicous: 等一下我先买个保险
Nicous: Wait a minute, let me buy insurance first.
Nicous: 然后我就装死
Nicous: Then I'll pretend to be dead.
Nicous: 我就没买呢
Nicous: I haven't bought it yet.
Nicous: 等一下等一下等一下
Nicous: Wait, wait, wait.
Nicous: 教我
Nicous: Teach me.
Nicous: 该到你请客了
Nicous: It's your turn to treat.
Nicous: 我无所谓
Nicous: I don't mind.
Nicous: 上次我请客
Nicous: I treated last time.
Choiszt: 但是不是谁输了谁请
Choiszt: But isn't it whoever loses treats?
Nicous: OK那今天谁输了谁请
Nicous: OK, then whoever loses today treats.
Tasha: 你昨天睡哪了
Tasha: Where did you sleep yesterday?
Tasha: 哦你们俩一起睡
Tasha: Oh, you two slept together.
Jake:那个走
Jake: Alright, let's go.
Jake:物美超市土桥店走
Jake: Wu Mart Tuqiao Store, let's go.
Tasha:不是说永辉吗
Tasha: Weren't we going to Yonghui?
Jake:到底是哪哈哈
Jake: Which one is it, haha.
Tasha:哦哦
Tasha: Oh, okay.
Tasha: 我没见过大的物美
Tasha: I've never seen a big Wu Mart.
Jake:那就见识一下
Jake: Then you'll see one now.
其他人:我好像之前物美就是一层
Others: I think the Wu Mart before was just one floor.
Tasha: 对就很小
Tasha: Yeah, it was really small.
其他人：非常有生活气息啊
Others: It's very down-to-earth.
其他人：简称很low
Others: Simply put, it's very low-end.
Choiszt: 他是两两层
Choiszt: It's two floors.
Jake:没事low一下
Jake: It's fine to be low-end.
Jake:low一low给这个看看真实北京
Jake: Let's be low-end and show a real Beijing.
Tasha: 不是很可爱
Tasha: Isn't it cute?
Tasha: 这是我的
Tasha: This is mine.
Jack: 这是你画的
Jack: Did you draw this?
Jake:画的
Jake: It's drawn.
Nicous: 你做的
Nicous: You made this.
Choiszt: 这不是直接买的就是这样的吗
Choiszt: Isn't this just bought like this?
Tasha: 我我一句话没有说呀
Tasha: I didn't say anything!
Tasha: 是的是买的呀
Tasha: Yes, it's bought.
Choiszt: 对呀这不一买了就这样
Choiszt: Yeah, you buy it like this.
Choiszt: 然后就贴墙
Choiszt: And then you stick it on the wall.
Nicous: 我以为你画的
Nicous: I thought you drew it.
Jake:哈哈哈总被他骗是吧
Jake: Haha, you always get fooled by him, right?
Tasha: 我什么时候骗骗你了
Tasha: When have I ever lied to you?
其他人：比如说你从现在开始可以玩五福星
Others: Like when you said you could play Five Lucky Stars from now on.
其他人：然后马上又遇到你输了哈哈
Others: And then you immediately lost, haha.
Choiszt: 藏藏一个币是什么
Choiszt: What's hiding a coin?
Jake:呃就是跟藏彩蛋似的
Jake: Uh, it's like hiding an Easter egg.
Jake:因为一个币它就是贴纸
Jake: Because a coin is like a sticker.
Jake:然后就客厅里面藏一藏
Jake: So you hide it somewhere in the living room.
Jake:他们找找到就是自己的
Jake: If they find it, it's theirs.
Tasha: 真的会存到我的账户里吗
Tasha: Will it really be credited to my account?
Jake:呃会吗
Jake: Uh, will it?
Jake:就看这个中央银行怎么操作的
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha: 帮我私自藏300个吧
Tasha: Hide 300 for me privately.
Tasha: 我给你凑九福星
Tasha: I'll get you Nine Lucky Stars.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahaha.
其他人：哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Others: Hahahahahahahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
Jake:画饼啊
Jake: Just making promises.
Nicous: 最高就七福星
Nicous: The highest is Seven Lucky Stars.
Tasha: 你不知道九福星是个隐形彩蛋吗
Tasha: Don't you know Nine Lucky Stars is a hidden Easter egg?
Jake:完了
Jake: Oh no.
Tasha: 真的你自己去搜吧
Tasha: Really, go search it yourself.
Tasha: 七福星九福星是隐形彩蛋
Tasha: Seven Lucky Stars and Nine Lucky Stars are hidden Easter eggs.
Tasha: 就九福星的话会有一棵树
Tasha: With Nine Lucky Stars, there will be a tree.
Tasha: 这棵树会帮你战斗
Tasha: This tree will help you in battles.
Tasha: 三星9 三星5费也打不过
Tasha: Even three-star level 9 or three-star level 5 can't beat it.
Tasha: 全三星5费也打不过
Tasha: Even all three-star level 5 can't beat it.
Tasha: 真的
Tasha: Really.
Tasha: 自己搜
Tasha: Search it yourself.
Tasha: 三星5费也打不过
Tasha: Even three-star level 5 can't beat it.
Tasha:全三星也打不过
Tasha: Even all three-stars can't beat it.
Nicous: 九级星是吧
Nicous: Nine-level star, right?
Tasha: 对九级星
Tasha: Yes, Nine-level star.
Nicous: 我操
Nicous: Damn.
Tasha: 咳咳咳全三星
Tasha: Ahem, all three-stars.
Tasha: 全三星物费都打不过九福星
Tasha: Even all three-star units can't beat Nine Lucky Stars.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yes.
其他人：这他妈的我感觉出门被车撞死
Others: Damn, I feel like I'll get hit by a car when I leave the house.
Tasha: 哈哈嗯
Tasha: Haha, yeah.
Tasha: 极心他就是控30-40分会出转职
Tasha: Extreme Heart will trigger a job change at 30-40 points.
Tasha: 而且他那个极心
Tasha: Plus, that Extreme Heart...
Tasha: 那个转职是不可合成的
Tasha: That job change can't be synthesized.
Tasha: 不能用铲子合
Tasha: You can't use a shovel for it.
Tasha: 所以要就是拿五福星打连败空30-40层
Tasha: So you have to use Five Lucky Stars to lose 30-40 rounds.
Tasha: 然后出5次连败
Tasha: Then have 5 consecutive losses.
Tasha: 这5次必须全部都是转职
Tasha: All 5 of those losses must be job changes.
Jake:上面有吗
Jake: Is it up there?
Tasha: 对啊
Tasha: Yeah.
Choiszt: 他们都在等啥呢
Choiszt: What are they all waiting for?
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: No idea.
Tasha: 大家都这么慢
Tasha: Everyone's so slow.
Tasha: 吃饭也是很慢的
Tasha: Even eating, they're really slow.
Tasha:明天好像更热
Tasha: Tomorrow seems even hotter.
Tasha: 他没有三亚热呀
Tasha: But it's not as hot as Sanya.
其他人:别提三亚了
Others: Don't mention Sanya.
Tasha: 真的要去吗
Tasha: Are we really going?
Tasha: 杨老板说好
Tasha: Jake said yes.
Tasha: 他很想去
Tasha: He really wants to go.
Tasha: 五一过后
Tasha: After May Day.
其他人：他说五一过后
Others: He said after May Day.
Tasha: 嗯他说
Tasha: Yeah, he said.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Tasha: 他说这周就先自己把数据处理一下
Tasha: He said he'll handle the data himself this week.
Tasha: 然后
Tasha: And then...
其他人：他先去三亚度假了
Others: He'll go on vacation to Sanya first.
Tasha: 哈哈哈他说这周先是
Tasha: Hahaha, he said this week...
Tasha: 你们工作人员
Tasha: You guys, the staff...
Tasha: 先把这些数据都整理好之后
Tasha: After you organize all the data...
Tasha: 然后正好等五一假期
Tasha: Then just wait for the May Day holiday.
Tasha: 三亚那边不忙了
Tasha: Sanya won't be busy then.
Tasha: 就5月45月5就直达三亚
Tasha: So from May 4th to May 5th, we'll head straight to Sanya.
Tasha: 然后在那10天
Tasha: And stay there for 10 days.
Tasha: 然后呢啊
Tasha: And then...
Tasha: 回家了
Tasha: We'll come back home.
其他人：那我们呢
Others: What about us?
Tasha: 你们你们回家
Tasha: You guys, you guys go home too.
Tasha: 你们也回来
Tasha: You guys come back too.
其他人：咱去不了
Others: We can't go.
其他人：为啥啊我正好毕设结束了
Others: Why not? I just finished my thesis.
其他人：卧槽
Other: Whoa!
其他人：那我去不了
Other: Then I can't go.
Tasha: 你为啥去不了
Tasha: Why can't you go?
其他人：他们毕设比我们真心慢
Other: Their thesis defense is way slower than ours.
其他人：其实我其实毕不毕设无所谓
Other: Honestly, I don't really care about the thesis defense.
其他人：他谈女朋友
Other: He's dating someone.
Tasha: 呵呵哦
Tasha: Haha, oh.
Tasha: 他们也是一天300
Tasha: They also charge 300 a day.
其他人：没钱啊我好像没钱
Other: I have no money, I think I'm broke.
Tasha: 那怎么交
Tasha: Then how do you pay?
Tasha: 你们不是发论文吗
Tasha: Aren't you publishing a paper?
Tasha: 发论文还要钱吗
Tasha: Does publishing a paper cost money?
Tasha: 没贴钱就不错了
Tasha: It's good enough if it doesn't cost extra.
Tasha: 对啊
Tasha: Yeah.
Tasha: 就是发这论文都要钱
Tasha: Just publishing a paper costs money.
Jake:来三个人来三个人
Jake: Three people, three people come here.
Jake:来3个人跟我走
Jake: Three people, come with me.
Tasha:我们俩
Tasha: The two of us.
Jake:唉吴美健对
Jake: Hey, Wu Meijian, yes.
Lucia:没有我随口一说
Lucia: No, I was just saying.
Jack: 能坐5个
Jack: It can seat five.
Jack: 算你吗啊
Jack: Including you?
Choiszt: 这算上我5个
Choiszt: Counting me, it's five.
Katrina: 那我跟你坐吧
Katrina: Then I'll sit with you.
Lucia:好可爱啊
Lucia: So cute.
Lucia:我要给他俩拍个照
Lucia: I want to take a picture of them.
其他人:什么
Other: What?
Lucia:石柿子
Lucia: Stone persimmons.
Jake:石柿子
Jake: Stone persimmons.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Jack: 打车在哪
Jack: Where's the taxi?
Jake:在哪车呃打车在这开车在那
Jake: Over there for taxis, driving over there.
Jake:好走
Jake: Alright, let's go.
Tasha: 自动分流自动分流
Tasha: Automatic diversion, automatic diversion.
其他人：自动分流开
Other: Automatic diversion activated.
Jake:哎把眼镜关了吧
Jake: Hey, turn off the glasses.
Shure: 关了
Shure: Turned off.
Lucia:到地再开
Lucia: Turn them back on when we arrive.
Jake:对到地再开嗯
Jake: Yeah, turn them back on when we arrive.
Lucia:怎么关来着我怎么突然不记得了
Lucia: How do you turn them off again? I suddenly forgot.
Tasha: error
Tasha: Error
Jake:complete
Jake: Complete
Lucia: 他是不是能检测到什么minor那个
Lucia: Can it detect something minor?
Jake:啊minor
Jake: Ah, minor
Lucia: minor quality
Lucia: Minor quality
Lucia: 什么什么
Lucia: What?
Jake:哦哦因为他要求比较高
Jake: Oh, oh, because its requirements are quite high
Jake:对
Jake: Right
Jake:就是记得时间长总会有一些帧会丢掉
Jake: Remember, if it's long, some frames will be dropped
Jack: 还会丢帧啊
Jack: Frames will be dropped?
Jake:呃时间戳还在
Jake: Uh, the timestamp is still there
Jake:我就一直没交钱嘛
Jake: I just haven't paid yet
Jake:但是绑了一个号
Jake: But I linked an account
Jake:就你给我
Jake: The one you gave me
Jake:我我打出去
Jake: I called out
Jake:我打进来
Jake: I called in
Jake:我每次打出去的话
Jake: Every time I called out
Jake:他就告诉我我的电话已经
Jake: It told me my phone was
Jake:对能接不能拨
Jake: Right, can receive but can't call
Lucia: 今天这刚好也比较远是吧
Lucia: Today, this place is quite far, right?
Jake:哎呀你俩见过吗
Jake: Hey, have you two met?
Jack: 没有在视频里面见过
Jack: No, just seen in videos
Tasha: 是吗
Tasha: Really?
Jack: 对就你那天给靖康打电话谴责他的时候
Jack: Yeah, when you called Jingkang that day to scold him
Jake:那天前几天疯狂炮轰我
Jake: Those days, a few days ago, he was crazily blasting me
Jake:我觉得不能给这个
Jake: I don't think we can give this.
Jake:就是这太BIAS的这个
Jake: It's too biased.
Jack: 小波尔全亚主义
Jack: Little Bohr's pan-Asia ideology.
Jake:读书人
Jake: Scholar.
Tasha: 读书魂
Tasha: Scholar's spirit.
Tasha: 这个您拿着行吗
Tasha: Can you hold this?
Jake:行可以
Jake: Sure, I can.
Tasha: 所以谢冰竹骗我说
Tasha: So Xie Bingzhu lied to me saying...
Tasha: 跟我在路路上打游戏的
Tasha: ...he was playing games with me on the street.
Jake:哦他没跟你打游戏
Jake: Oh, he wasn't playing games with you?
Jack: 里面还不是立刻商场
Jack: It's not an instant market.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:我去
Jake: I'll go.
Jack: 是商城
Jack: It's a mall.
Lucia:但是有榴莲耶
Lucia: But there's durian.
Tasha: 尊都哎
Tasha: Respect.
Jake:这是什么个价呀
Jake: What's the price?
Tasha: 这是干窑的呀
Tasha: It's from Ganya.
Tasha: 嗯不爱吃干窑的
Tasha: Hmm, I don't like Ganya's.
Tasha: 噔噔噔噔噔噔噔噔噔
Tasha: Dun dun dun dun dun dun...
Tasha: 你走了
Tasha: You left.
Jack: 我建议先买一瓶补水
Jack: I suggest buying a bottle of moisturizer first.
Tasha: 这不要一个购物车吗
Tasha: Don't we need a shopping cart?
Jake:哪有购物车
Jake: Where's the shopping cart?
Tasha:不知道呀
Tasha: I don't know.
Jack: 入口吧应该
Jack: Probably at the entrance.
Jake:我靠华为
Jake: Damn Huawei.
Jack: 外国见识一下中国的神秘力量
Jack: Foreigners get to see China's mysterious power.
Jake:太神秘了
Jake: So mysterious.
Jake:我靠
Jake: Damn.
Lucia:华为
Lucia: Huawei.
Jake:华为太神秘了
Jake: Huawei is so mysterious.
Tasha:哪呢
Tasha: Where?
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Tasha: 那呢购物车
Tasha: Where's the shopping cart?
Tasha: 怎么怎么回事
Tasha: What's going on?
Lucia:我去购物车在外面
Lucia: I think the shopping cart is outside.
Tasha: 感感觉这个超市有点不太正经
Tasha: Feels like this supermarket is a bit sketchy.
Jake:这太村了
Jake: This is too rural.
Jack: 哎逆天啊
Jack: Amazing.
Jake:这车怎么样
Jake: How's this car?
Jake:好车挑个好车呗
Jake: Pick a good car, come on.
Jack: 还行还行
Jack: It's okay, it's okay.
Jake:那就他了
Jake: Then let's go with this one.
Jack: 至少他万向轮看起来是万向的
Jack: At least its caster wheels look like they're working.
Jake:他一直在转
Jake: It's always spinning.
Jake:确实很万谢谢
Jake: It's really versatile, thanks.
Jack: 他有一点
Jack: It's a bit...
Jack: 他有点歪
Jack: It's a bit crooked.
Lucia:他有点bias了
Lucia: It's a bit biased.
Jack: 他有个轮不转
Jack: One of its wheels isn't spinning.
Jack: 你看他右前轮是不转
Jack: Look, the right front wheel isn't spinning.
Lucia:哈哈哈还是bias吧
Lucia: Haha, it's still biased.
Jack: 我心里有点过分
Jack: I'm feeling a bit overboard.
Lucia:是
Lucia: Yeah.
Jack: 还可以有fire
Jack: It can still catch fire.
Tasha: 你的风景
Tasha: Your scenery.
Lucia:这不是一点bias吧
Lucia: This isn't just a bit biased.
Jack: 这个轮真的不会动
Jack: This wheel really won't move.
Lucia:缺乏鲁暴性
Lucia: Lacks robustness.
Jake:他是个三轮车现在
Jake: It's a tricycle now.
Katrina: 是吗
Katrina: Really?
Jack: 大红袍
Jack: Da Hong Pao.
Tasha: 要不要把这个放车里
Tasha: Should we put this in the car?
Jake:好买了一个pad
Jake: Okay, bought a pad.
Tasha: 买了一个包
Tasha: Bought a bag.
Lucia:买了一个充电宝
Lucia: Bought a power bank.
Jake:买了个人哈哈哈
Jake: Bought a person, haha.
Jack: 我能不能先搞杯喝的
Jack: Can I get a drink first?
Jake:去
Jake: Go ahead.
Tasha: 现在就可以打开喝
Tasha: You can open it and drink now.
Jack: 打开一会结账是吧
Jack: Open it and pay later, right?
Jake:对对可以
Jake: Yes, yes, you can.
Tasha: 对一般在超市里面吃吃喝喝
Tasha: Yeah, usually in the supermarket, you can eat and drink.
Tasha: 拿着拿着一大堆开过的去结账
Tasha: Carry a bunch of opened items to the checkout.
Tasha: 也是可以的
Tasha: It's okay to do that.
Jake:可以那咱也喝点
Jake: Okay, let's drink too.
Jake:我请你们喝
Jake: My treat.
Tasha: 冰糖雪梨冰红茶
Tasha: Rock sugar pear iced tea.
Tasha: 我我已经开始报了
Tasha: I'm already reporting it.
Jake:你报报他
Jake: You tell him.
Lucia:哈哈冰糖雪梨冰红茶
Lucia: Haha, rock sugar pear iced red tea.
Lucia:可口可乐
Lucia: Coca-Cola.
Jake:元气森林
Jake: Yuanqi Forest.
Lucia:没有常温的嘛
Lucia: Don't you have any at room temperature?
Tasha: 嗯我想喝库尔橙汁哦
Tasha: Hmm, I want to drink Cool Orange Juice.
Lucia:那个我也好久没喝了
Lucia: I haven't had that for a long time too.
Jake:哪个橙汁
Jake: Which orange juice?
Lucia:有一个叫库尔
Lucia: There's one called Cool.
Tasha: 库尔
Tasha: Cool.
Jake:哦库尔哦
Jake: Oh, Cool, right.
Jack: 哦是那个
Jack: Oh, that one.
Jack: 嗯那个什么
Jack: Hmm, that what?
Jack: 类似那种
Jack: Something like that.
Jake:20年前
Jake: 20 years ago.
Lucia:对小时候好像
Lucia: Yeah, when we were kids.
Jack: 动画表情那个小孩
Jack: The kid with the animated expression.
Jack: 哦还真的是有二层
Jack: Oh, it really has a second floor.
Lucia:上面这二层看着像仓储式超市一样
Lucia: The second floor looks like a warehouse-style supermarket.
Jake:这是大桂哦
Jake: This is Big Gui.
Tasha: 为什么
Tasha: Why?
Jake:打打一下
Jake: Dial it.
Jake:打哎他应该是打我电话了
Jake: Dial, hey, he should be calling me.
Tasha: 对就是我听到了
Tasha: Yeah, I heard it.
Tasha: 手手表一直在震
Tasha: My smartwatch keeps vibrating.
Jake:我们一起打他电话
Jake: Let's all call him together.
Tasha: 呼叫失败
Tasha: Call failed.
Lucia:会忙线吧
Lucia: The line might be busy.
Lucia:一起打
Lucia: Let's call together.
Jake:我们一起打他电话
Jake: Let's all call him together.
Jake:看谁能打到
Jake: See who gets through.
Jake:总会有一个能打
Jake: Someone's got to get through.
Lucia:这算群殴吗哈哈
Lucia: Does this count as a group attack? Haha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Jake:我们来四四个
Jake: Let's get four of us.
Jake:谢冰竹哈哈哈哈
Jake: Thank you, Bingzhu, hahaha.
Lucia:哈这算群殴吗
Lucia: Haha, does this count as a group attack?
Tasha: 呼叫失败
Tasha: Call failed.
Lucia:我微信网络不稳定i don't know why
Lucia: My WeChat network is unstable, I don't know why.
Jack:  unable to connect China game
Jack: unable to connect China game
Lucia:我现在用的应该是移动
Lucia: I'm using mobile right now
Lucia:不是电信的网啊
Lucia: It's not a telecom network
Lucia:怎么还这么差
Lucia: Why is it still so bad
Tasha:对方忙
Tasha: The other party is busy
Tasha: 怎么
Tasha: What
Jake:那就接你的
Jake: Then just connect yours
Lucia:你这个t恤标志换了
Lucia: You changed the logo on this t-shirt
Jake:哎是
Jake: Yeah, I did
Jake:对这是第一版
Jake: This is the first version
Lucia:变成他们学校的校徽了
Lucia: It turned into their school emblem
Jack: PSG了
Jack: PSG now
Jake:这不是
Jake: This isn't
Tasha: 怎么办他不接你打电话吧
Tasha: What to do if he doesn't answer your call
Jake:我欠费我停机
Jake: My account is overdue, it's suspended
Tasha:欠费了
Tasha: Overdue
Jake:我停机了
Jake: I'm suspended
Lucia:他刚解释过
Lucia: He just explained that
Jake:对刚解释过
Jake: Yeah, just explained
Jake:打不出去电话
Jake: Can't make any calls
Jake:那就换一个人打吧打刘帅
Jake: Let's have someone else call, call Choiszt
Jack: 他不应该在门口啊
Jack: Shouldn't he be at the door
Jake:他可能找不到
Jake: He might not find it
Tasha: 感觉这个超市好小呀
Tasha: This supermarket feels so small
Jake:这个超市
Jake: This supermarket
Jake:对一开就开过了
Jake: Yeah, once it opened, it just opened
Tasha: 就是那种开了二三十年的感觉
Tasha: It feels like it's been open for 20-30 years
Jake:嗯经典
Jake: Yeah, classic
Lucia:没事给AI增加一些数据多样性
Lucia: It's okay, add some data diversity for AI
Jake:对是的
Jake: Yeah, right
Jake:不能总盒马
Jake: Can't always use Hema
Jake:太赛博了
Jake: Too cyber
Jake:夹不上
Jake: Can't grip it
Tasha: 没加他算了
Tasha: Didn't add him, forget it
Jake:路亚也来打一个哦
Jake: Also, Luyah come make a call
Lucia:哦
Lucia: Oh
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah
Tasha:怎么说我们都开始逛了
Tasha: What do you mean we already started shopping
Tasha: 就这个终于打通了
Tasha: Just this, finally got through
Jake:哦这个你打通了
Jake: Oh, you got through.
Tasha:对
Tasha: Yes.
Jake:哎你好
Jake: Hey, hello.
Jake:你好啊你在哪里啊
Jake: Hi, where are you?
Lucia:怎么跟第一次见面一样
Lucia: It's like meeting for the first time.
Jake:哪位啊
Jake: Who's this?
Tasha: 哪位哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Who's this? Hahaha.
Jake:啊刚好停好车是吧
Jake: Ah, you just parked, right?
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake:地下停车场
Jake: The underground parking lot.
Jake:行行行我们在
Jake: Alright, alright, we're at...
Jake:我们到华为等你们
Jake: We'll wait for you at Huawei.
Tasha:我们在
Tasha: We're at...
Jake:我们在华为
Jake: We're at Huawei.
Jake:我们去华为等你们
Jake: We'll go to Huawei and wait for you.
Jake:你们你们找华为啊
Jake: You, you're looking for Huawei, right?
Jake:华为对一楼
Jake: Huawei, right, the first floor.
Lucia:那卖的可是衣服啊大哥
Lucia: But they sell clothes, bro.
Jake:但是这不是华为吗
Jake: But isn't this Huawei?
Jake:我说那是华为
Jake: I said that's Huawei.
Jake:他是不是华为哈哈哈
Jake: Isn't that Huawei? Hahaha.
Lucia:您说不是
Lucia: You said it isn't.
Lucia:不是您说是
Lucia: Not you, you said it is.
Lucia:谁敢说不是哈哈
Lucia: Who dares to say it's not? Hahaha.
Tasha: 噔噔噔噔
Tasha: Dun dun dun dun.
Lucia:你倒着推他会
Lucia: If you push it backwards,
Lucia:他会更稳一点吗
Lucia: Will it be more stable?
Jake:他他会更稳一点
Jake: It'll be more stable.
Lucia:OK
Lucia: OK.
Jake:因为他前面导向的是稳定的
Jake: Because the front part provides stability.
Tasha:我也想坐
Tasha: I want to sit too.
Jake:那你坐啊
Jake: Then sit.
Jake:请
Jake: Please.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Lucia:坐这个吧浅一点好坐
Lucia: Sit on this one, it's shallower, easier to sit.
Jake:请请请
Jake: Please, please, please.
Lucia:高温烧制
Lucia: High-temperature firing.
Tasha:猜它是釉上彩还是釉下彩
Tasha: Guess if it's overglaze or underglaze?